ja ich glaube dass wir heute den beginn
einer neuen ära gesehen haben und zwar
der ära markus söder jetzt werden viele
von ihnen sagen ja markus söder der ist
auch schon länger in amt und würden in
bayern und auch schon länger csu chef
das ist richtig aber wir haben heute den
beginn einer neuen ära gesehen des
dominanten markus söder in der gesamten
union also auch in der schwesterpartei
cdu denn das was er heute gemacht hat
das war muss man sagen schon ein
machtpolitisches meisterstück aus
münchen hat er nicht nur die
jamaika-koalition
abgepfiffen die tür zugeschlagen für ein
bündnis von union fdp und grünen auf
bundesebene er hat auch quasi die
karriere von armin laschet beendet indem
er gesagt hat jamaika wird es nicht
geben und da hat darauf hingewiesen dass
die union an einem wendepunkt steht in
die opposition muss das heißt markus
söder wird jetzt politik machen gegen
eine ampel koalition in berlin
mutmaßlich eine ampel koalition in
berlin sein klares ziel ist die
landtagswahl in bayern in zwei jahren
die er für csu fulminant zurück gewinnen
will mit einem ergebnis 40 plus und wenn
er das hinbekommt politik zu machen aus
bayern für bayern aber dann auch als
opposition gegen die ampel in berlin
dann wird er über kurz oder lang ohnehin
der ganz ganz starke mann in der union
sein der der die volkspartei csu
deutlich über 40 prozent bekommen klar
ich bin der meinung er ist ein
bayerischer bac und und sollte das nicht
schaffen ja weil ich bin für märz schon
seit 15 jahren seit ich diese man es
erst immer gehört deshalb werde ich
nachher noch ausführen ja und er hat
jetzt vielleicht ein überraschungserfolg
ist auch nicht sonderlich schwer an dem
scherbenhaufen aber das wird keine
langfristiger jubel darüber zu berichten
aber das ist sie weiß ich was ich finde
frau bat man kann viel sympathie für
friedrich merz haben aber wenn ich mir
anschaue was in der cdu schon wieder
passiert wie hintenrum hier und da
taktiert wird aber niemand geht offen
raus und sagt armin laschet
das war's lieber armin laschet du hast
gut gekämpft du bist persönlich ein
toller typ aber du bist jetzt der
falsche für die parteispitze ich möchte
nicht beerben das passiert alles nicht
dass eine feige partei und weder
friedrich mehr als noch jens spahn noch
norbert röttgen hat bisher eigentlich
klar gesagt
dass er kandidieren möchte markus söder
ist da anders der hat seine positionen
ganz klar bezogen in dem fall spielte
hier mit offenem visier dies spricht
heute für ihn sicherlich aber ich würde
so sagen ich meine das ist der
scherbenhaufen von angela merkel auch
die hat die ganze zeit die richtig guten
jungs weggebissen also wenn ich mir die
gefolgschaft von irrt also angeguckt
haben und wie die traktiert worden
ich habe cdu noch gewählt ich habe die
immer gewählt ich bin 60 jahre alt ich
habe immer angela merkel gewählt cdu ja
einfach nicht wegen der personen sondern
wegen dem spirit als unternehmerinnen ja
und zweitens ist der freiheitsgedanke
noch sehr groß kann man sich die zweite
stimme vorstellen mal gibt ja in
deutschland nie zu wenn man gewählt hat
ja aber ich muss ehrlich sagen bei den
herren fällt einem immer schwerer und
ich hoffe dass die in den nächsten auto
hatte bei der letzten wahl noch armin
laschet eine stimme gegeben er in der
cdu ja aber da ist es auch nicht viel
besser aber im prinzip die spd will mich
einfach an cdu ja einfach weil man nicht
die person auch immer welt schon
inspiriert aber ich sag ja lange rede
gar keinen sinn dass werden im
ortsbereich geben die nächsten vier
jahre und dann sehen wir weiter und will
sagen ich bin kein fan von so dass auch
ich finde dass er tritt sehr sehr
autoritär auf ich finde er erwürgt er
sie
also entschuldigung dass ich nicht sagen
muss aber
und ich bin schon erstaunt darüber dass
er so beliebt ist in der bevölkerung
dass er so hohe beliebtheitswerte
einfährt mich wundert dass aber das
zeigt mir wieder dass die deutsche
bevölkerung ich glaube der fehlt so ein
bisschen diese führung die angela merkel
einfach nicht gegeben hat die angela
merkel die auch ausgemacht weil sie sich
eher zurückhaltend gezeigt hat er auch
die anderen hat für sich sprechen lassen
aber markus söder ist mir zu autoritär
natürlich auch in teilen der politik was
er gezeigt haben das bestätigt jetzt zu
sein sein sein vorgehen dass er da so
eine art hat dich der ich nicht folgen
kann das hauptproblem bei era söder wie
du es nennst jan die jetzt angeblich
beginnt ist ja das ist gar nicht drauf
ankommt wie die deutschen das kommt ja
in der politik gar nicht darauf an wer
der beliebteste ist wer am besten beim
volk ankommt wer die größten chancen in
dem wahlkampf hat wer auch die größte
chance in einem parteiinternen rennen
hat sich durchzusetzen da spielt er in
der politik wissen wir seit diesem
wahlkampf keine rolle da stellt man den
kandidaten auf der die geringsten
chancen hat und deswegen wird die cdu
das auch schaffen markus söder weiter zu
verhindern er wird wunderbar weiterhin
beim volk angekommen er wird die wahlen
in bayern genau wie du sagst ja grandios
gewinnen aber die cdu wird das ist
zuletzt dank des schulischen und
beruflichen geister scheiden ließ hat
den stärksten auch eine sache für mich
ich bin ja wirklich bei vivien für mich
ist markus söder eine ich ag markus
söder nicht nur markus söder markus
söder hat sich auch in der hohen ab
anime-serie touristisch weiter zeit
lässt letzterer ist für mich mit dem
beispiel von heute ein intrigant und
sein verhalten ist unmöglich also muss
man sich wirklich mal überlegen das ist
doch alles konträr zu dem was einem
beigebracht wir können ja noch sein aber
es war jetzt ja keine persönliche
bewertung die ich vorgenommen aber über
den menschen markus söder sondern es war
die bewertung eines machtpolitiker das
kann man doof finden oder oder gut aber
ein politiker der nicht macht haben
möchte der bringt es nicht weiterkommt
über den wahrscheinlich den ortsvorsitz
gar nicht hinaus und zeigt mir ein
politiker der keine ich ag ist natürlich
ist jeder politiker eine ich-ag
ausgelegt oder eine war weniger ausgibt
wir anderen kann halt aber ag
leben ist dass die cdu wahlen gar nicht
gebildet individuen
2018 in bayern war es kein gutes
ergebnis bei der bundestagswahl hatte
losgedreht er stelle lag weit hinten und
hat den ball das ergebnis war ich
schlecht ich glaube es war es historisch
ich weiß nicht es war das historisch
schlechteste ergebnis seit 1953 der aber
an armin laschet für die schuld gegeben
deswegen abgesagt worden deswegen
brauchte die ampel in berlin was wir da
waren gewaltig ich höre dass immer
wieder aber ich frage mich wo ist denn
das belegbare beispiel wo man sagt
markus würde hat ein krasses
wahlergebnis erzeugt bei den wählern ich
würde eher sagen er ist kein guter
machtpolitiker weil er eben nicht dass
partei spiel beherrscht weil er nicht
volker bouffier auf seine seite gezogen
hat der jeder sieg ihm anders enden dass
er nicht mensch ist und daher ist und
aber es ist jetzt dass dadurch ein
bisschen wie der arche bei der frage ist
es eigentlich gar nicht die bevölkerung
die entscheide ich glaube sie
entscheidet schon es mag einzelne
entscheidungen geben die nicht immer der
der das dem erfolg dienlich sind das hat
man in der union gesehen haben auch die
grünen den 13 der entscheid die daten
aufgestellt natürlich aber den wir uns
umfragen anschauen beispielsweise dann
ist ja markus söder in der beliebtheit
der engagiert deutlich vor armin laschet
olaf kölzig große kunst keine große uns
aber olaf scholz trotzdem auch das ist
noch mal wichtig zu sagen steht im
moment zwischen kino krupa und janine
wissler ja das ist schon ein echtes und
olaf scholz hat die wahl nun gewonnen
seine spd hat gewonnen und er war von
den kandidaten den drei
kanzlerkandidaten immer der beliebteste
also ich hab der bürgerwille
25,7 glaube ich ja ja sag mal lächerlich
finden aber am ende hat er die meisten
stimmen geholt das mag nicht jeden
erfreuen aber nur cdu wählerin schon gar
nicht das verstehe ich auch dass man
darüber dann empört ist aber wir müssen
es glaube ich akzeptieren die kernfrage
ist ja gibt es so jemanden wie markus
söder auch in der spd der so dominantes
da gibt es zwei parteivorsitzende gibt
es jetzt ein kanzler wird der kanzler
dominanter als die beiden
parteivorsitzenden ich glaube das
machtvakuum in der cdu das ist einfach
jetzt sehr groß und das nutzt markus
söder als csu-chef einfach aus und
drängt da rein aber dieses game merkt
man ihm an also da bin ich komplett sein
es wirkt ehrlich gesagt für mich auch
leicht intrigant und menschlich einfach
unterste schublade wie er sich gerade
verhält macht es eine sache man braucht
auch führungen ich glaube gerade weil
wir so lange angela merkel hatte hatten
die jetzt eher zurückhaltend war würde
uns ist gar nicht unbedingt schlecht tun
wenn wir jemanden haben der wirklich
auch klartext redet weil das hat man
also das habe ich auch bei angela merkel
vermisst aber markus söder also eine
frage ganz provokant her woran warum ist
es schlimm und das meine ich jetzt nicht
als persönliche bewertung aber nur
gefragt warum es so schlimm dass jemand
intrigant ist das werden wo ist das
problem also wenn jemand es geht ja um
die frage wird hier eine ära begründet
und ich sage ja hier wird eine ära
begründen aber ich bin politiker haben
bei dem ich das gefühl habe das ja gute
werte hart dass der nicht hinterlistig
ist und einfach das herz am richtigen
fleck und da würde ich auch wieder
sprechen jetzt amerikaner so
aufrichtigkeit schon tatsächlichen
anzustrebende wert in der politik aber
der die wähler haben das wort und wenn
die wähler feststellen dass er ist ja
dann gut wenn die wähler feststellen
markus söder ist so ein intrigant den
wenig dann frage ich mich aber auf der
anderen seite ist das wirklich der
maßstab in jeder wieder anlegt weil das
wird man immer wieder angebliche markus
wieder so intrigant komischerweise hat
ja deutlich bessere werte als armin
laschet von dem jeder erzählt der wehr
so lustig und so nett und wenn der jetzt
hier bei uns am tisch sitzen würde
hätten wir alle einen wahnsinnig
lustigen und fröhlichen abend aber
offenbar ich wollte mir die bürger aber
auch sehr viel spaß haben das ist nicht
der punkt nicht klappt das so ich will
keinen champagner trinken cola light bis
jetzt ein problem also aber ich glaube
solche typen die so mit der faust auf
den tisch haut und so ein temperament
haben wie der die mag ich eigentlich
auch sehr gern ja so ist es nicht aber
barbara friedrich merz das ist ja ein
heimlicher favorit
weil für mich ein ausgewiesener
finanzexperte ist und macht die
nachrichten ahnung was geht um geld und
geld und das und jenes jeder punkt ist
dann immer mit fehlendem geld verbunden
ja oder mehr schieben es geld von dahin
nach dorthin und das traust du friedrich
merz am meisten zusagt kann besten
verschieben ich traue eben nicht nur den
verschiebebahnhof zu die regeln sondern
ich traue ihm auch zu dass er produktive
strukturen anleitet ja und die familie
staat ja in letzter zeit wenig und habe
extreme bedenken dass sie in der zukunft
kommen
[Musik]